Everything in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has slowly been building up to the arrival
of Thanos, and after years of waiting, Avengers:
Infinity War is finally here.
Which raises just one big question for superhero
fans: now what?
Of course, Marvel has already allegedly created
a meticulous master plan that runs through
the year 2028.
But since they aren't telling anyone what
they have in mind, we'll just have to look
at the clues to figure out just how Infinity
War will change the MCU forever.
Expect departures
The contractual obligations for many of the
stars of the MCU end with Avengers: Infinity
War.
Rumors and reports have circulated for years
that some of the MCU's biggest stars would
be unwilling to renew, with Robert Downey,
Jr., Chris Evans, and Chris Hemsworth all
stating at various times that they were planning
to leave the MCU at the end of their contracts.
Of course, people can change their minds,
and being offered hundreds of millions of
dollars often helps.
But considering pretty much every Marvel superhero
was killed in the Infinity Gauntlet comic
book series that Infinity War is based on,
it would seem like Marvel has been planning
the perfect sendoff for the current version
of the MCU - and the current lineup of stars
- for years.
While most are signed through the Infinity
War follow-up in 2019's Avengers 4, chances
are pretty good that Infinity War is at least
the beginning of the end for everything you've
known and loved about the MCU for the past
decade.
Expect new arrivals
If the thought of losing your favorite superheros
is a big ol' bummer, don't worry, because
Marvel has plenty of other characters waiting
in the wings for their closeup.
Sure, some of the characters left in their
stable may not be as famous as their current
line-up, but be honest: had you ever heard
of the Guardians of the Galaxy before they
became the coolest thing in any universe?
What about Doctor Strange, or Ant-Man, or
even Iron Man?
Yes, hard as it may be to remember now, but
Iron Man was once considered a second string
hero, and featuring him in his own solo film
was regarded as a massive risk when the first
Iron Man film came out a decade ago.
So don't worry if you've never heard of Moon
Knight, Brother Voodoo, or Shang-Chi, Master
of Kung-Fu.
Because given Marvel's track record, chances
are they'll be your new favorite character
before the final credits finish rolling.
Expect more diversity
The undeniable critical and commercial success
of Black Panther should be enough to convince
even the most doubtful cynic that after Infinity
War, we should expect to see Marvel Studios
doubling and tripling down on its commitment
to diversity.
Starring mostly actors of color, written and
directed by people of color, Black Panther
proved — if nothing else — there's no
good reason to shy away from Marvel's collection
of more diverse heroes.
With the success of Black Panther, the highly
anticipated Captain Marvel waiting in the
wings, Avengers: Infinity War's ensemble cast
featuring numerous people of color and women,
the persistent whispers of a solo Black Widow
movie, and a still largely untapped reserve
of Marvel comics characters waiting for their
names to be called, Marvel movie fans should
expect to not only see more women heroes and
heroes of color, but their real-life counterparts
writing and directing.
Expect more laughs
Marvel movies are funny, and they'll continue
to be funny.
Though the Avengers franchise, which sits
at the heart of the MCU, has been a deadly
serious affair with deep real-world themes
and moral debates, it's also been laced with
all sorts of funny gags and light asides.
[Sound of a body being repeatedly slammed
into the ground]
"Puny god."
Unlike the DC Extended Universe, films in
the MCU are actually fun to watch, and as
films like Guardians of the Galaxy and Thor:
Ragnarok have proven, the more audiences laugh,
the more money they're likely to spend seeing
it again.
Thor: Ragnarok was even so fun that star Chris
Hemsworth reportedly has been reconsidering
his decision to leave the MCU.
And all that added humor helped Thor: Ragnarok
earn not just the most money of the three
Thor films, but also the best reviews.
In fact, one of the few criticisms of the
movie was that it might have been too funny!
Given the success of Ragnarok in revitalizing
one of Marvel's key franchises, though, don't
expect the laughs to stop any time soon, especially
with Ant-Man and the Wasp and Guardians of
the Galaxy vol. 3 already in the pipeline.
The events of Infinity War may be sad, but
chances are, Marvel has a plan to turn that
frown upside down sooner rather than later.
Expect more variety
Maybe the biggest secret to Marvel's success
is the fact that while they seem to be making
superhero movies, they're actually making
movies from all sorts of different genres
that just happen to feature superheroes as
the main characters.
Think about it.
Captain America: Winter Soldier was a classic,
70's style espionage movie.
Guardians of the Galaxy was a space opera,
while Doctor Strange and Thor: The Dark World
were fantasy films.
Ant-Man was a heist flick, while Ant-Man and
the Wasp has been described as a romcom, and
Spider-man: Homecoming was their take on the
classic John Hughes high school dramedy.
It's that non-formula formula that has worked
so well for Marvel up until this point, so
fans should expect to see more of the same
- by expecting less of the same when it comes
to Infinity War.
Marvel isn't going to follow up their big
smash em up epic action crossover with more
of those.
Instead, they're likely to branch out even
further, picking characters that work well
in different types of films.
Want to see a Marvel western?
They've got the Two-Gun Kid for that.
A Marvel horror movie?
How about Simon Garth, the Zombie?
A Marvel war movie?
Hello, John Kowalski!
It sounds weird, but Marvel plays it safe
by not playing it safe, so going forward,
expect even more variety than we've gotten
so far.
Expect more space
One of the corners of the Marvel Universe
that has found nothing but success is the
cosmos.
Both Guardians of the Galaxy films were hits.
And, like humor, the cosmic element added
to Thor: Ragnarok was a key ingredient to
turning around the franchise.
While the first Avengers brought us an alien
invasion, Avengers: Infinity War promises
an even stronger attachment to Marvel's cosmic
mythology than ever.
With Quasar, Nova, Adam Warlock, Moondragon,
and more, there are almost as many heroes
among the stars as there are on Marvel's Earth.
And the possible acquisition of Fox's properties
opens even more doors.
The Fantastic Four are cosmic explorers, and
the Silver Surfer is the ultimate cosmic hero.
Considering all the success Marvel has had
in space, and the fact that its audience is
now familiar enough with its cosmic mythology
to not burden future films with extraneous
explanations, there is no reason to think
Marvel won't explore other far out franchises.
Expect complete Annihilation
So what will Marvel's next giant film crossover
event be once Infinity War and Avengers 4
have come and gone?
Well, if Marvel does use Infinity War and
the acquisition of the Fantastic Four and
the Silver Surfer as an excuse to launch even
more cool outer space movies, the next logical
step is complete Annihilation.
That's because in the comics, while the Earth-bound
heroes were all busy fighting each other with
their Civil War thing, Marvel's space heroes
were engaged in a galaxy-spanning Armageddon
called Annihilation, with the Guardians of
the Galaxy leading the way.
With Infinity War bringing the alien menace
to Earth, the next logical step for our heroes
is to take that fight back into space.
Of course, Marvel has plenty of other massive
crossover storylines they could do instead,
but given the popularity of their sci-fi franchises
- and the space connections evident in 2019's
Captain Marvel, which seems set to include
the space war between the Kree and the Skrull
- Annihilation seems like the safest bet.
Expect the X-Men
Finally, the acquisition of Fox would provide
the MCU with the most obvious new direction.
Now that the threat from without has been
taken care of, what about the threat from
within posed by the emergence of a mutant
population hiding among us?
With the Avengers potentially gone, who could
possibly stand up to the danger of…
The X-Men?!
It's inevitable that the X-Men will play a
major role in the MCU once Disney has rights
to the characters, we just don't know yet
how it will play out.
Will Thanos use the reality-warping Infinity
Gauntlet to somehow merge the MCU with Fox's
X-Men universe?
Or will the characters develop organically,
with the X-Men franchise getting rebooted
completely - like Spider-man was - so that
the emergence of the mutant menace becomes
the cornerstone of Marvel's next Phase, and
beyond?
However Marvel ends up bringing the X-Men
into the MCU, once they are there, there's
no question that they're going to be at the
center of everything that follows - and not
necessarily as heroes.
Could the MCU follow the comics by having
Cyclops become the big bad guy in a race war
between humans and mutants?
In a world without the Avengers as we know
them, anything is possible.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!